en este vídeo quiero dar un montón de
propiedades que cumplen los límites pero
no voy a demostrar nada eso lo haré en
otro vídeo cuando tome la definición
rigurosa del límite con nep si no si de
altas ahora aquí la mayoría de estos
casos son simplemente bueno te
simplifican bastante la vida cuando
haces límites ahora digamos que sabemos
que el límite de alguna función de
alguna función f x el límite de alguna
función f x mientras x se aproximasen es
igual a l y digamos que también sabemos
que el límite de alguna función otra
función g de x mientras se extiende a c
es igual a m y ahora bien da con esto
cuál sería el límite de fx + gdx
mientras x se aproximase bueno tú
podrías de hecho visualizar esto mirar
las gráficas de dos funciones
arbitrarias simplemente las sumas sumas
estas dos funciones y será bastante
claro entonces bueno una vez más no
estoy haciendo la prueba rigurosa de
esto solamente te estoy dando las
propiedades y bueno esto es igual al
límite
fx mientras se extiende a ser más el
límite de gx mientras se extiende a ser
lo cual esto es igual esto es igual lo
voy a ponerme con otro color naranja
entonces este límite aquí es el entonces
el más y el otro límite es m así que el
mcm y no es tan difícil esto
regularmente tiene nombre se le llama
propiedad de la suma del límite extra y
otra muy similar es la de la diferencia
de límites el límite mientras x se
aproximase de fx
x simplemente será l - m simplemente es
el límite de fx mientras x tiende a ser
menos el límite de gx mientras se
extiende a ser por lo tanto esto es
igual a l menos
l - m lo cual es comúnmente llamado la
propia edad de la diferencia entre
límites y bueno espero esto sea aunque
creo que creo que esto es bastante
intuitivo pero qué pasaría si tomamos el
producto de la función el límite de fx
por gd x mientras x tiende a se extiende
así y bueno suertudos nosotros porque
esto será igual al límite de fx mientras
se extiende a cm por el límite de gx
mientras se extiende a cm y corremos con
suerte porque así es muy fácil
recordarlo cierto esta propiedad es muy
sencilla así que en este caso esto es l
por ml x
l x m bastante sencillo el asunto yo
creo ahora am lo mismo sería si en lugar
de tener una función aquí tuviéramos una
constante si simplemente tuviéramos el
límite luego lo voy a hacer en otro
color
entonces en el mismo color techo
entonces bueno el límite de acá por fx
mientras se extiende a c donde k es una
constante esto será lo mismo que acá por
el límite de fx mientras x se aproximase
lo cual es simplemente esto es igual a l
entonces esto es simplemente esto es
igual a k por él y bueno genial el
nombre de esto el nombre de esto se le
llama la propiedad del límite con
múltiplo constante y podemos hacer lo
mismo con la división si tenemos si
tenemos el límite mientras se extiende
hace de fx sobre eje x esto es
exactamente lo mismo
el límite de fx mientras se extiende
hace sobre el límite de gx mientras
extiende hace lo cual esto es igual creo
que ya sintiendo un poco mejor el asunto
cómo va todo esto es igual a él es sobre
m cierto esto es l y estos elementos l
sobre m y a esto se le llama la
propiedad del cociente y finalmente la
propiedad del exponente en sí yo tengo
lo voy a escribir bueno si yo tengo el
límite de fx elevado a alguna potencia y
lo voy a escribir como una la potencia
en forma de fracción r sobre s donde r y
s son enteros
entonces el límite el límite de fx
elevado a la r sobre s mientras se
extiende hace esto será igual al límite
de fx el límite de fx mientras se
extiende hace todo elevado a la r sobre
s donde r s son enteros y ese es
distinto de 0 claro porque si si no
fuera distinto de 0 esto no tendría
mucho sentido de acuerdo
entonces esto es lo mismo que el elevado
al aire sobre ese l esto es igual a l
elevado a la potencia eres hombre s así
que usando estas propiedades podemos
hacer cualquier cosa en la vida bueno
podemos podemos encontrar varios límites
y lo genial de esto es que las
propiedades cumplen lo que esperarías
que hicieran es todo muy intuitivo